des chercheurs français britanniques et
américains ont identifié au cameroun le
groupe de singes considéré comme
réservoir naturel du virus du sida
ces chants pas et porteurs sains du
virus serait à l'origine de la pandémie
mondiale qui a déjà fait 26 millions de
morts est infect aujourd'hui 40 millions
de personnes frédéric mental
les singes sont ils à l'origine du sida
la question se pose depuis 25 ans
aujourd'hui le doute ne semble plus
possible les chimpanzés sauvages du
cameroun sont bien les premiers porteurs
du virus hiv à l'origine du sida
c'est la découverte d'une équipe
internationale de chercheurs bientôt
publiée dans la revue science
quatre ans dans quête dans les forêts
les plus reculés du cameroun 600
excréments analyser et une conclusion
chez certains clans de chimpanzés un
singe sur trois est porteur sain du hiv
le virus existerait même depuis des
milliers d'années
alors c'est toujours la question clé
c'est effectivement pourquoi le système
immunitaire du chimpanzé qui est pas si
différent du nôtre arrive à contrôler
l'infection alors que nous n'y arrivons
pas et ça reste une voie avec bien sûr
de recherche pour la mise au point d'un
vaccin fondamentale le virus s'est
propagé par morsure ou blessures entre
chasseurs et chimpanzés certains ont pu
être contaminées en mangeant de la
viande de brousse dans les années 30 les
premiers explorateurs des forêts de
l'afrique de l'ouest sont touchées dans
les années 60 le virus se répand dans
les capitales africaines avec la
multiplication des lignes aériennes le
sida débarque en europe aux etats-unis
en amérique du sud avant d'envahir le
reste du monde
aujourd'hui le sida touche 40 millions
de personnes 26 millions de morts depuis
le début de l'épidémie
cette découverte va peut-être mettre un
terme aux folles rumeurs sur
l'apparition du sida comme celle qui
accusait les laboratoires militaires
américains